this is Jason's place and this is Neil
what a treat this is Jake you're doing
alright and he's wearing like I don't
know what this is it's somebody this is
you man hand is in the center of a
galaxy now so maybe they didn't tell him
that in the side of the galaxy is a
supermassive black hole so the head is
now sitting in a freaking black holes
well the desert thing that the term sub
is already the term singularity is what
happens at the center of the black hole
so maybe there's not a singularity I
want to be this that is ristic because
that presumes is that we actually know
the cosmos doesn't in there enough all
right I can imagine a species far more
intelligent than we yes that'd make us
look like worms
I think that's possible well that's so
therefore we are a way for the cosmos to
badly stumble upon itself right now we
are a way for the cosmos dukakis exactly
there we go let's start there